And exercise is supposed to be good for
you. And of course, the darling of the
medical system for exercise was Jim Fix.
Uh he was a long-distance runner. He was
a professor of economics in one of the
Ivy League schools. And he was the
darling of the medical world because
when he was interviewed on TV and asked
if he took any vitamins, minerals, he
says, "Nah, you don't need to do that.
Don't take any vitamins, minerals. Just
run. You'll keep your arteries clean."
Well, he dropped dead while he was
running a marathon at age 52. And so,
uh, his theory didn't work. It was a
failed theory. his protege, Brian
Maxwell from Canada, died at 51 while he
was running. He had 12 gold medals for
long-distance running. Three were in the
Olympics and uh he invented the Power
Bar and he sold the rights to the Power
Bar to Nestle's Corporation and three
months after he received his $3 million,
he drops dead during a run card up with
a heart disease, a deficiency of a
single mineral just like Jim Fix. Now
because of this the journal of the
American Medical Association did a
literature review um which was published
in December of 1982. In September of
1982 Jim Fix died and they did this um
literature search because he was their
hero and they they were just really
freaking out because here we are our
hero dies of a heart attack while he's
running and um they published it as a
kind of letter to the editor thing in
the Journal of the American Medical
Association in 1982.
Also they publish it later on as an
abstract in running world or runners
world magazine. They said while running
a man's risk of heart attack death
increases by
700% while
running increased by a factor of
700%. Now that shocked everybody because
they thought exercise was good. Well
when you take all professional athletes
of all sports
combined and you look at them from an
average lifespan, their average lifespan
is 62. When you take out professional
football players, their average lifespan
is
51. There's never been a professional
athlete ever lived to be 100. So what
does that say to you about exercise?
There's something problematic about
exercise. It's not what it was led to
you to believe it was. So what's going
on here is when you sweat, you're not
sweating out water. Sweat is not water.
But yet athletes will go to great
extents to rehydrate using water or
they'll drink these sports drinks that
have two nutrients in them or six
nutrients. And as a result, they begin
to break down. They'll get torn
cartilage in their knees. They get c
torn cartilage in their hips. They'll
get torn muscles, torn tendons or
achilles tendon. They'll get cramps.
They get all kinds of stuff. And they
have to get taken off the field on the
stretcher and so on. And then some of
them die, okay? Because they're sweating
out all the nutrients floating around
their blood. If they're not
supplementing, they may only have 55 or
60 nutrients which you're sweating out.
If they're supplementing, they may have
90. But if you're not supplementing and
you're exercising, you're in real
trouble. Okay?
Reggie Lewis, captain of the Boston
Celtics, collapsed during a playoff game
with the Charlotte Hornets. He survived
that first card of the heart attack and
he was given a drug to kind of support
his heart function and he was told to do
light exercise like throwing free show
like throwing free throws from the free
throw line on a court. And two weeks
later after his initial attack, he died
of a second cardiammyopathy heart
attack. If Reggie Lewis had been given
10 cents worth of selenium, he'd still
be alive today as he died of a simple
selenium deficiency disease. Moses
Malone, NBA Hall of Famer, dies at 60 of
a cardiammyopathy heart attack. Rowdy
Rody Piper, dies at 61 from a
cardiamopathy heart
attack. This fell here, a cardiologist
and a soccer star in Brazil, drops dead
at age 57 from a cardiamopathy heart
attack. So why is it the strength
exercise is unhealthy? is because you
must supplement to replace all the
nutrients you're sweating out. Really
that
simple.
Obesity, as we pointed out in the
beginning, is not due to eating too much
and lack of exercise. Obesity is in fact
a simple nutritional deficiency and
there's no end in sight for the obesity
epidemic because those nutrients are
disappearing from our food faster and
faster. The symptoms you get from that
deficiencies are cravings, binge eating,
and the munchies.
Experts tell us that 70% of our kids
under the age of 12 are overweight. 40%
of our kids under the age of 12 are
obese. 30 pounds or more of their ideal
weight for their height. This has
nothing to do with eating too much or
lack of exercise. This is caused by
nutritional deficiency. Totally
preventable, totally reversible quite
quickly to half a pound to two pounds a
day. This is a kind of a false uh story.
This is a false flag attack so to speak.
I guarantee this little baby who's under
two years of age is not eating super
sized bags of French fries. Not going to
happen. But he is obese. And if he was
eating these French fries and continue
to eat them from then on, the odds are
he would die of a coronary artery
disease at age 10 or 12 years of age
because of the trans fats, heterosychic
means and the acryumides in the French
fries. He's obese because he's deficient
in nutrients. Now this is everywhere USA
in 1920. This is when they began the
theory that lack of exercise and eating
too much was the cause of obesity. Of
course, these girls are getting a lot of
giggles here, but this has nothing to do
with their cause of obesity or their
repair themselves or getting rid of
their obesity. They're going to have
fun. They're going to waste some time,
but they're not going to solve their
problems here. It's a nutritional
deficiency problem. Here's a mother in
Brazil who ate um 20 bath sponges with
soap suds and skin um dandruff in it as
well as the the parrot droppings as well
as the sand in the bottom of the parrot
cage because she had such crazy
cravings. And of course, pregnant women
are legendary for gaining baby fat
during pregnancy. That's because they're
missing nutrients because the embryo is
stealing nutrients some of them faster
than they're getting them themselves.
And this is Ivan, of course, met him
about three years ago. And Ivan weighed
423 pounds when I met him. He lost on
our program with our supplementation and
nutrients. Lost 17 pounds in the first
week. He lost 60 pounds in the first 30
days. That's two pounds a day. And he
dropped down from 400 lb to 165 pounds
in 7 months. And two years later, his
picture's on the right. And um he of
course two years later is still looking
good and hasn't gained back a quarter of
an ounce. And this is because this is a
simple nutritional deficiency. You take
the nutrients, it goes away. You take
the nutrients, you don't get fat. Just
that simple. In horses, the the behavior
called munchies is called cribbing. You
can see here the horse is not even in
that stall in the barn is a horse and
buggy Amish farm in which is south of
Fort Wayne, Indiana. And uh the buggies
bringing the babies with must late and
being a physician and a veterinarian.
And I said, "Well, there's a barn here.
I'll go look at the animals." And sure
enough, there's a cribbing evidence
there. And so I knew that that horse in
that barn was deficient deficient in
minerals. You give them minerals and it
stops. You give people the right
minerals and the obesity goes away. It's
just very simple. Osteoporosis and
arthritis, simple mineral deficiencies,
simple vitamin deficiencies. It's not a
complex disease at all. It's a simple
nutritional deficiency. Every tissue in
our body, every organ in our body wants
to go away. It's kind of like sand on a
beach or paint on your house over time
getting beat up from the weather and the
temperature changes and so forth. What
happens is is everything goes away.
Well, if you're not taking in the raw
materials to maintain it, like paint
your house every year, right? That kind
of thing. Um, change your oil every
3,000 miles, you're going to have
problems. And arthritis and talking
about the coming epidemic of arthritis,
that's because we no longer have the
right nutrients in our food anymore.
We'll get into that in a moment. Now,
colas are linked to bone breaks,
fractures, because when you take in
calcium for your bones, and often times
doctors will do that. You just give
people calcium, you need all 90
essential nutrients for bone health. But
if you're going to take in calcium along
with the other nutrients, you have to
have the right ratio between calcium and
phosphorus. There's got to be two
calcium for one phosphorus if everything
is going to work well. If you drink
colas, even diet colas, regardless of
what brand of cola it is, guess what?
You're going to have four phosphorus for
one calcium. And that scenario is going
to leech all the minerals out of your
bones. And that's why you find a lot of
young athletes get fractures just
running down the field because they're
drinking lots of colas. Calcium
deficiency causes kidney stones. The
first thing in a medical doctor will
tell you is stop eating dairy. And for
goodness sakes, don't supplement with
any calcium when in fact calcium
deficiency is a cause of kidney stones.
What happens is your parathyroid glands
don't like that. They reach into your
bones and they suck out minerals,
particularly calcium. And that calcium
that your parathyroid gland is pulling
out of your bones raises your calcium
level in your raises your calcium level
in your blood as well as um causes
kidney stones. Failed medical theory.
Popular osteoporosis drugs are linked to
hip fractures. Why is that? You know
1800 bad drugs. Why is that? Because
they were
phosphorus.
Fazamax too much phosphorus not enough
calcium and it causes demineralization
of your bones. Another failed medical
theory. Big surprise. Another failed
medical theory is that osteoporosis is
caused in women when they go through
menopause because they don't have enough
estrogen to keep calcium in their bones.
That's an absolute lie. It's not true.
Men actually get osteoporosis at a
faster rate than women more seriously
and faster rate. You see all these
little old guys with canes waddling
around in the in the um malls and
airports and shopping centers and
grocery stores and so forth. They have
osteoporosis. And of course, um, this is
a failed theory that women got it and
men didn't because women went through
menopause, had reduction, lost their
hormones. That was a nonsense, absolute
criminal, um, theory, and somebody
should go to jail for that one because
they killed so many men who fell and had
hip fractures when they should have been
on mineral supplements to prevent that.
This young fell here, the prince of
Dubai, Shik Rashid, died at 33 while he
was running. You can see he's a very fit
young fella, a runner, played soccer,
played rugby, and he was held up as the
kind of fitness guru in Dubai, kind of
leading the country in their health. Uh
he was also the guy who was going to
become the king when the king died and
he drops it at age 33 while he was
running cardiammyopathy heart attack, a
simple deficiency of a single mineral.
And so hopefully we're going to Dubai
and to teach the people there that they
have to supplement. No matter how
wealthy you are, you still need to
supplement to make sure your tissues are
receiving everything they need. Terrible
tragedy. Terribly
unnecessary. Andy Young from the civil
rights movement. Also, he was the
ambassador United Nations under Jimmy
Carter. He was the mayor of Atlanta for
a couple of terms and he called me from
uh San Diego to come to Atlanta in his
home and speak to him because of my work
in cickle cell anemia uh not being
genetic. And we were talking about that
and I noticed he was limping. I said,
"With all due respects, Mr. ambassador,
why are you limping? He says, "Well, I
got bone to bone arthritis, both my
knees, and um I'm scheduled at Emory
University, the group that fired me for
my cystic fibrosis research, um uh to
have a double knee replacement." I said,
"Sir, with all due respect, uh I can
regrow your carage. I can support and
promote maintenance repair by
supplementing with a program we call the
healthy bone and joint pack." He said,
"Well, these are the best surgeons,
arthopedic surgeons in the world, and
they say you can't." They said, "Well,
sir, with all due respect, they're
liars." Okay? we can in fact support and
promote maintenance and repair and you
will regrow your cartilage. And he
didn't want to have the surgery. So he
canceled the surgery and let me rebuild
his knees in 90 days. We rebuilt his
knees and we became very good friends
and we do lots of great things around
the world
together. One of the things he did was
introduce me to this young lady, Delicia
Jones. She was the center on the US
women's Olympic team that had won two
gold medals in the Olympics, the
basketball team. and uh getting prepared
for their third run at the Olympics uh
she tore her hamstring and Achilles
tendon on the right hand side and the
surgeons who are going to put her
together said Delicia you know we can
put you together mechanically but you
might not play at the same skill level
because of these injuries are very
devastating and you might consider
coaching well she didn't like that she
went to Andy Young and he referred her
to me again using the healthy bone and
joint pack we're able to um support and
promote maintenance repair of the
muscles and the tendons and ligaments
and cartilage regrrew to her and they
went back and won their third gold
medal. And this is me giving her an
award, a certificate for sharing her
story with other athletes. And um I
often wonder why do women who are 6'5
wear 8 inch
heels. Okay. Knee surgery arthritis is
worthless. This was a study from Harvard
Medical School published in the New
England Journal of Medicine. This was
July
2002.
And this is where we like to refer
people. They looked at 300,000 sets of
records from people who had knee
replacement, hip replacement, shoulder
replacement surgeries. They found out
that the disease just kept getting worse
and worse and you had to replace that
device every couple of years because the
bone would get thinner and thinner and
actually might tear and rupture and
break. And so they said ultimately knee
replacement surgeries for arthritis, hip
replacements, and shoulder replacements
are worthless. And so, you know, give us
90 days with a healthy bone and joint
pack and let us support and promote
maintenance repair and see what happens.
you're going to be very happy because by
supporting and promoting maintenance
repair, we can support and promote re
repair and re reappearance and regrowth
of that cartilage. No matter what your
doctor says is
doable. Four years later, November 2006,
that same group of orthopedic surgeons
from Harvard Medical School looked at
the same 300,000 records, but this time
they looked at the backs of these same
people. They said back surgery
unnecessary for sciatica, low back pain,
for um things like um peripheral
neuropathies. And so again, we can
support and promote maintenance repair
with the what we call the healthy bone
and joint pack. It has all 90 essentials
nutrients in it and gives the body the
raw materials it needs to support and
promote maintenance repair. Diabetes,
there's an epidemic right now in the
world. It's doubling. Diabetes is
doubling almost every year now in
America. Right now in America, 30% of
Americans either have diabetes or
pre-diabetes. It's breaking us
financially. It's breaking the American
medical system financially. Okay? It's
breaking our country financially. Is one
of the big contributing factors to the
national debt of almost $19 trillion is
type two diabetes. Why is there an
epidemic? Because there's none of this
mineral in the soil. Remember, it's a
deficiency of a single mineral. We've
known that for almost 80 years.
The big story to show you it's not a
genetic disease goes to the Puma Indians
and above the line where the line goes
through the P and underneath the I under
Puma. Um you see a big yellow band looks
like a big yellow banana there in the
eastern part of Mexico. But above that
line that goes through the P and
underneath the eye, you'll see it's the
same genetic pool. That whole yellow
area above that line which is the border
for Arizona between Arizona and Mexico,
mainland of Mexico. And below that
border, you can see that big yellow
swath. That is the range of the peum
Indians. They're the one of the few uh
Native American tribes that did not
intermix with other Indian tribes. They
did not intermix with the released black
slaves after the civil war was over. Uh
they never intermix with the explorers
from Spain and Portugal and France and
Germany. And so they're almost
pure same genetic pool across the
American border in the American side and
below the American border in the Mexican
side. And here's a couple of pictures of
the Puma Indians. Same genetic pool.
Now, remember this is the exact same
genetic pool. The group of uh young men
on your left are Puma Indians are
typical of those in Mexico. They're tall
and slim. They live in a third world
country situation. Don't have any of the
amenities of the Western world. They're
still using horses or plowing and wagons
to haul stuff around drawn by horses.
And they look pretty good. The ones on
the right are above the border in
America in Arizona. And you see they're
all obese. Even the children are obese.
They have their vans and their pickup
trucks and so forth. They all work in
factories instead of being subsistance
farmers like the ones in Mexico. Let's
have a look at the rate of diabetes. The
Mexican Puma Indians have a rate of type
two diabetes of 6%. The American Puma
Indians, which are written up as the
culture in America that has the highest
rate of type two
diabetes, 46%. The average American rate
is considered like 33% a third and so
they are 30% higher than that. It's 46%.
Now we know it's not genetic because
it's the same genetic pool. So what
could it be? Well, we know it's a
mineral deficiency. But why? There's a a
thin line going between those two
peoples and yet there's such a
difference between them. Why is this?
You'll see in just a
moment. Again, diabetes cases double.
Kids are being born with type two
diabetes now. not only type one
diabetes, but they're being born with
type two diabetes. And here's a three
and a half year old, okay, from Houston
and she's three and a half years of age,
but she weighs as much as a 10-year-old
and she has type two diabetes. More
blacks lose legs to diabetes than
whites. This is one of those things
where the black gene book comes in,
black gene lies. Uh, more blacks lose a
leg to diabetes than whites. Why is
that? It's not a genetic thing. is
because the medical system has been able
to capture the black community and tell
them that all their diseases are genetic
and if they stick with the medical
community, the medical doctors will save
them from their genetic diseases. And so
whatever the doctor says, they don't
question it. They don't get a second or
third opinion. They just do what the
doctor says and the doctor abuses them
financially as well as kills them early.
This fell here, Jerry Murphy, owns one
of the largest medical diagnostic labs
in America, um, Gamma Labs, Gamma Labs.
and he had terrible type two was running
well over 200. His blood pressure was
running well over 200. His A1C
hemoglobin was like nine or 12 instead
of five or below. And to make a long
story short, uh we made a wager because
we had a mutual friend who said I could
help him with his diabetes. And um he's
very skeptical of course working with
the medical community and he says,
"Look, Wallik, we'll be best friends.
We'll do a lot of good things for
America together if you can do what you
say. If you can't, I will destroy you.
I'm going to make a CD. I'll have bounty
hunters pass them out everywhere you go
and I will dog you until you're
destroyed if you fail. He said, "Okay,
Jerry, you're on." He was quite shocked
that I so quickly said, "Okay, let's do
it." Well, make a long story short, in
three months time, his A1C hemoglobin
was below five and his blood sugar was
down to like 90 or been running 240.
Okay? And he's now totally diabetes
free. He's a wonderful friend and we
just uh love him to pieces because he
does great things for us, too. Cancer is
not a genetically transmitted disease.
It is a self-inflicted
disease. Everything you do either
prevents cancer or causes cancer. And
so, let's have a look. Doctors and
researchers, they're so interested
because it's such a horrible disease,
they want to run in, get the cure right
away. And they fail every time to find
the cure. The first prevention research
was done and published in
1912. It was on the benefits of selenium
and preventing cancer. They published it
in Popular Mechanics magazine. Now, why
did they publish something like that in
Popular Mechanics magazine? That's
because they brought it to all the
medical journals of the day and they
wouldn't they wouldn't publish it.
That's nutrition. We're not interested
in that. That was 1912. Well, in 1998,
u the University of Arizona redid the
same study, redid it, got the same exact
results showing they could reduce the
risk of prostate cancer by 65% 69%. You
reduce the risk of breast cancer by 32%.
Reduce the risk of colorectal cancer by
95% by supplementing with
selenium. Published it in the annals of
medicine which is very well respected
medical journal. High fiber diets don't
cut colon cancer rates as another failed
theory. Bacon ham sausages are big
cancer threat equal to smoking and
working in an asbestous environment.
Now, I've been yelling about this for 45
years since I did those autopsies in the
center for the biology of natural
systems. And the World Health
Organization two weeks ago made the
announcement. The World Health
Organization will publish a report on
Monday, which was two weeks ago, on the
dangers of eating processed meats. The
World Cancer Research Fund has warned
for several years that there is strong
evidence that consuming a lot of
processed meats cause uh consuming a lot
of processed meats such as ham, bacon,
and salami increases the risk of colon
cancer and many other types of cancer.
Okay. They also say that it probably,
I'm quoting them now, probably all red
meat causes cancer. That's not true.
It's how you cook the red meat, okay?
Will be a factor. This was study
published in 1998 from the University of
South Carolina. And they were working on
the Harvard Nurses Health Study, 90,000
nurses, 20 years. And their piece was to
evaluate the rate of breast cancer in
women and how they cook their food.
Okay, they're getting down into that
area of of interest. Well, they found
out that the women who cooked their meat
very well done where the fat was
severely browned or burnt increased
their risk of breast cancer by
462%. The ones who cooked their meat
medium rare and the fat remained
white reduce the risk of breast cancer
by 462%. So that's a 900% difference
between the most extreme you're going to
get it to the most extreme you're not
going to get it. And what a wonderful
thing just how you cook your food
determines whether you're gonna get
breast cancer or not. Then there was
some wonderful research by Dr. Dr. Ghart
Schrazer, great biochemist from
University of California, who showed
very clearly that you could reduce the
risk of breast cancer by 82% just by
supplementing with 200 micrograms, 1/5if
of a milligram of the trace selenium.
Remember, he said mammograms are not
prevention and they're they're dangerous
because one mammogram has radiation
equal to 500 chest X-rays. Also we find
out that and this is very recent in
October of 2015 61% 61% of all positive
mammograms are ne are false positives
and they say you know we just this is
too complicated here so we have to have
a biopsy get a bopsy you know this is
unequivocal but we're concerned and so
let's air on let's take the breast off
and do radiation and and um
um chemotherapy
So they get they're hit in they build
the insurance company or Medicare
Medicaid for a couple hundred thousand
dollar and the doctor is happy kills the
patient. Hot dogs cause butt cancer.
This is directed towards kids. These are
highway signs you'll begin seeing on the
highways around America. Genetics have
nothing to do with cancer. Have nothing
to do with cancer. Eating fried foods,
processed meats with nitrates and
nitrites cause the problems.
Arsenic is known to be an essential
nutrient since
19 47
1947. And today even the medical school
at the New York University proved
unequivocally that they could put um
people with acute proistic leukemia, the
most vicious and most aggressive type of
leukemia into remission in just a couple
of months. And 10, 12, 15 years later,
they're still in remission. They didn't
want to call it a cure because it's a
essential nutrient. Steve Jobs dies at
56. Saturro Awata, CEO of Nintendo, dies
of 55. His parents buried him at age
55. Dementia, there's five different
types of dementia. There's an old law
that says you can't have all five.
Vascular dementia, arteries are clogged
in your brain. Same way they're clogged
in your heart and your and your kidneys.
Alzheimer's disease, a cholesterol
deficiency, corov syndrome, a deficiency
of a single vitamin. Warnick corres
which is the deficiency that single
vitamin and uh also MS mixed in with it
multosis vitamin B12 deficiency dementia
you can have all five of these at the
same time. Okay now remember Alzheimer
disease is caused by a cholesterol
deficiency is not genetic not caused by
aluminum.
This is my favorite slide on Alzheimer's
disease. The mother is 82 years old. The
son's 58. They're both have Alzheimer's
disease. They're both in the same
nursing home. They both have the same
doctor. They're on the same cholesterol
diet. They're on the same statin drug
prescribed by that doctor. The doctor
also owns the nursing home they're
in. You should be getting a picture
here. Somebody needs to go to jail. This
came out in 1992. And this is one of the
reasons that my original audio cassette
tape dead lie was so controversial.
Vitamin E can ease memory loss and
Alzheimer's victims. And I added a
prepositional phrase when I read this.
This was research from the Sock
Institute in the University of of H
California, San Diego. Vitamin E may
ease memory loss in Alzheimer's victims,
which means it cannot be genetically
transmitted because there's no vitamin
there's no pharmaceuticals can affect
how a a genetic disease manifests
itself.
Two years later, um the John's Hopkins
School of Medicine, very famous, very
well respected in Baltimore, Maryland,
uh went to the Cache Valley, Utah, and
they found 5,000 people over the age of
65 who had no dementia, no serious
disease, no heart disease, high blood
pressure, kidney disease, nothing. Um
and so they found them, they put them on
two vitamins, vitamin C and vitamin E,
because they were excited about this
vitamin E story that came out two years
earlier. And 10 years later, um, again,
they had half these 5,000 people on this
supplement and the other half they put
on a dummy pill. At the end of the 10
years,
2004, they opened up the envelope and
undid the the map. And the ones that got
the vitamin C and E had 78% less
Alzheimer's disease. Now, they all ate
the same way. They're all from the same
culture. They all came from Scotland.
All these five 5,000 people came from
the same religion. They were Mormons.
They read the Book of Mormon. They were
also um using the supplement called the
words of wisdom, which tells them what
to eat, what not to eat. Kind of like
the Jewish kosher
approach. And so there's more to it than
just those two vitamins. Also, uh they
were all um subsistence farmers much
like Amish. Very, very basic, very
conservative farmers. Only ate what they
grew. No restaurants or hotels in their
in their valley where they lived. And so
he actually had an analysis done of the
of the floor of that entire valley. We
know all the mineral veins and
everything what's in there. And so in
the book epigenetics, it goes into great
detail why these people had such a
wonderful reduction in the rate of
Alzheimer's disease just by
supplementing those two vitamins,
vitamin C and E because they enhance the
value and function of other things is
why type two diabetes has got to be
genetic because we have three
generations of type two diabetics in our
family. No, that's not true. Have you
ever heard of gluten intolerance? Gluten
intolerance is generational. It's not
genetic. It's not an allergy, but it is
generational. And it causes eczema,
dermatitis of all kinds, belly problems,
belly pain, headaches, um all kinds of
nasty stuff. Celiac disease,
appendicitis, diverticulitis, irritable
bowel syndrome, inflammatory bowel
disease, Crohn's disease, asthma,
chronic bronchitis, pneumonia every
winter time, eczema, rosacea,
dermatitis, psoriasis, infertility. It
can contribute to a thousand other
diseases because these other diseases
are nutritional deficiencies and gluten
intolerance changes the efficiency of
absorption out of your intestines. If
you can't absorb the nutrients, you have
a problem. But let's say uh let's talk
about type two diabetes and you only
have 2% of the mineral you need to
prevent diabetes in the soil where
you're living and you're eating from
local farmers
markets and now you have a gluten
intolerance and you only have 10% of
your availability of absorption. So,
what's 10% of 2%.
0.2%. You're going to get diabetes. Has
nothing to do with genetics. And here is
the villi. Those little red finger-like
projections on the left hand side of
your screen. And these villi increase
the absorbive surface of the
intestine. Well, here's a study on white
rats. On your left hand side are the
healthy villi. You can see the little
villi. This is microscopic picture.
Obviously, uh the normal ones. You can
see all the increased surface for
absorption. In the middle picture, those
same group of rats were put on um a
heavy gluten diet for six months. You
can see the loss of the villi and the
scar tissue beginning to form in between
them. On the right hand side, it's a
year of a heavy gluten diet. And look at
all the scar tissue. They've lost almost
100% of their villi and the intestinal
lining is replaced with scar tissue. How
do you absorb nutrition through there?
You can't. And this is what gluten does
to you. It's kind of like putting poison
ivy on your skin. You get a contact
dermatitis. With gluten, you get a
contact entritis, okay? An inflammation
of the intestines caused by this protein
which is very, very irritating. Okay?
Now, the nice thing about this is if a
10-year-old kid or a three-y old kid or
a six-month old kid gets on a
gluten-free diet, in a couple of weeks
time, you're going to see a dramatic
benefit, particularly if you're giving
them the 90 essentials of nutrients. Um,
let's say somebody in their 20s and 30s
and 40s gets on a gluten-free diet.
Within a month, you're going to see
something dramatic in a positive way,
and it might take them a full year to
repair. People who are in their 50s,
60s, 70s, and 80s been eating gluten
five times a day and oatmeal for
breakfast every day, drinking a couple
of beers every Friday night and having
bread and pasta and crackers and gluten
and whole grains all the time. It might
take them two years to get a return to
normal on a gluten-free diet, but they
might show some dramatic thing you can
see as a benefit within maybe six
months. Just depends on how long and how
severe the gluten damage is. Here's a
perfect example. Little Jussi on your
left was born with eczema and asthma.
His mother was born with the same eggs
and asthma. She's 28 years old when she
delivered him. She'd had three
miscarriages and um she had the same
eggs and asthma and she's breastfeeding
him. So we gave her a gluten-free diet.
We put her on the 90 essential
nutrients, 16 minerals, 16 vitamins, 12
amino acids, three fatty acids. And in
two weeks time, her asthma or eczema
she'd had for 28 years went away.
that same two weeks you see in the
middle there his asthma and eczema went
away in two weeks time because he's
getting all his nutrients through his
mother's breast milk. Now interesting
thing about this the pediatrician who's
caring for him the only thing he told
the mother was here's some
hydrocortisone cream rub it on his skin
to prevent the itching and also told her
to clip his fingernails and put mittens
on his hand so he wouldn't scratch
himself in his sleep. Well here he is on
the right at two years of age and you
can see how happy he is. He, you can
tell by looking at him, he doesn't have
asthma and eczema. We see this all the
time in kids. And the ones on the left
have their eczema, dermatitis,
psoriasis, and the ones on the right,
they've been without gluten for anywhere
from a month to six months. And um
they're getting the 90 essential
nutrients. You can see the difference.
Very dramatic. This lady was this way
for 23 years. Her dermatologist made $3
million treating her for 23 years. And
of course, in 90 days, gluten-free diet,
90 essential nutrients, this is all
reversible.
Longevity, one in five Americans are
disabled. 20% of Americans are disabled.
We're supposed to have the finest
medical system in the world. We don't.
We have the most expensive medical
system in the world, but it's
problematic. Remember that 85% of all
personal bankruptcies America due to
medical bills. This just shows you the
prevalence. It's the same pattern in the
continental United States. It's always
the south um eastern states. It's always
the um Atlantic border there. We run up
and down the Atlantic Ocean and also the
states around the Great Lakes. Also the
southwestern states and up in the
northwest where they have Indian tribes,
the worst of the worst when it comes to
disabilities here. Okay. And this is
cancer. Here's one a little bit of a
departure. The the state that has the
worst cancer rate is Kentucky.
And of course, the reason why they have
such terrible cancer is there's very few
of the minerals in the Atlantic
seabboard. There's very few of these
minerals in the south eastern part of
the United States, the old Confederate
States, and the Indian reservations out
west. There's one particular state, they
fry everything. Kentucky, they fry
everything. It's rumored they fry water
and that's why they have such a high
rate of cancer. Life expectancy, the
red, yellow, and orange are the shortest
live, and the ones in the blue counties
are the longest lived people. There's a
25-y year difference between the longest
lived people and the shortest lived
people in America simply because of the
mineral supply in their soil where their
food is grown and whether or not they
fry food. The ones in the blue don't fry
food and the ones in the reds and orange
and yellows do. Out west, southwest,
west of the Mississippi River, Indian
reservations, old Confederate states in
the southeastern part of United States
and eastern seabboard. Same thing for
males. Statin drugs speed up aging
process. Women go through menopause in
their 30s. low TED in males regardless
of age. Alzheimer disease we're now
finding in 30 year olds and 20 years
olds because it has nothing to do with
age, nothing to do with genetics. It has
to do with a cholesterol deficiency. If
you're very very good like vegetarians,
vegans who are really driven to stay
away
from animal products and cholesterol and
saturated fat and they take satin drugs,
many of them, not all, but many of them.
and they're the ones who have a high
rate of Alzheimer's disease and hormonal
problems. So I urge everybody to get a
hold of these books, Black Gene lies,
epigenetics, immortality, and rare
earths cures. And you'll learn why the
top 20 longevity cultures live so long.
What is what are their secrets? They
have 23 common threads. And of course,
I'm going to show you what I believe are
the more important ones after this uh
after these pictures. But I want you to
look at immortality. Look at the cover
of that book. I want you to look at the
top picture above that yellow line just
below the neck of that statue there.
It's a fire. I want you to pay attention
to that fire because this is very very
important in why the top longevity
culture, the top 20 longevity cultures
are all third world cultures. Calorie
restricted diets, these same top 20
longevity cultures only take in 600 to
900 calories a day. Not because they
know the the science, they're
illiterate. They're they're third world
cultures. But they're so poor they can
only afford 600 to 900 calories a day.
Americans taking 2500 to 4,000 calories
a day. This fell here, George Francis,
died at 112 in December of 2008. Was the
longest lived documented man in America.
He lived considerably longer than 19
presidents he lived through whose
average lifespan was 75. The doctors who
cared for these presidents documented
the average lifespan came out in 1999 in
a big study published in medical
journals is 56, exactly half of the the
years that George Francis got. Now he
lived in a uh a house. It was a cabin
that his great-granddaddy built during
the slave days. A pot belly stove, dirt
floor, was a croad fisherman and and
fisherman. Sold those things to
restaurants, Cajun restaurants. And he
lived to be 112, double the lifespan of
medical doctors who took care of
president. So what was the secret? When
he died, his daughter was asked by the
reporters and his daughters reading the
newspaper to him there. The daughter
said when she was asked, "What did your
daddy do to be 112?" She said, "He broke
all the rules of healthy eating. He
cooked in lard and ate butter and cream
and eggs." In fact, she said his entire
diet was dairy products, eggs, and lard
sandwiches. Also on the right hand side
you see the Russian Mismolof 168 years
of age is a very famous picture in the
National Geographic where he is working
in his tea uh plantation and also
listening to a transducer radio at 168
years of age. Man from Syria died at 133
years of age. National graphic cover May
2013 this baby will live to be 120. Look
at the grammar there. This baby will
live to be 120.
She's from the decline peninsula on the
Pacific coast of Costa Rica in Central
America, one of the poorest poor
countries and cultures on Earth. Okay,
these are the long lived people in in
the Western
Hemisphere. What's going on here? Why do
they have 40 times 100 as we do? Why do
they have 100 per 250 their population?
We Americans only have 100 over 10,000.
This fellow is from Bolivia, the second
longest lived culture in the Western
Hemisphere. He's putting llama manure in
his wood stove. There's a high-tech
kitchen. He's 102. This fell here is
from Florida when he turned 101. He
actually got a whole M1 on his 101st
birthday. We need to find out what he
does and make sure that Tiger Woods gets
the information. These are the longest
lived people on Earth, the Hanzas from
the Hanza Valley in the Carakarum
Mountains that separate northern
Pakistan from China. They're the longest
lived people on Earth. They live at
13,000 ft elevation and they're
descendants of Alexander the Great. when
he moved east from um Greece after he
won all the battles there. Uh he moved
east towards China and of course having
babies along the way. These people live
at 13,000 foot elevation. You can see
they're obviously third world and they
live in what we would call the land
flowing with milk and honey. The Guiltar
Glacier, which is about a mile wide at
13,000 foot elevation. Okay. The water
that comes out from underneath the
Guiltar Glacier looks like milk because
the glacier is grinding up limestone.
And so the limestone powder comes out in
the water. It looks like milk. And bees
love minerals. And so there's lots of
bees there. The land flowing with milk
and honey. This is biblical. This is a
biblical location. This is where people
did well. Uh they were successful in
business. They were healthy. They lived
long time, had healthy children. In
Okinawa, it's not all Okinawans live
well or long. It's only a very small
group of people up in one mountain on
the side of one mountain. They um live
to be an average of 85. Everybody else
lives be 52 to 60. So it's not all of
Okinawa that lives well. It's just one
little subculture. Now the reason is, of
course, we'll get into in a second. We
spend a lot of time with this fellow
here, Mr. Taguchi, who's 102 years old,
and he lives in this little subculture
up on the side of this mountain. And so
we know exactly what they do to live so
long. And here's the oldest gal up
there. She's a pop star. She goes around
with a singing group and she's a lead
singer in a singing group singing pop
songs. And you can just tell by looking
at her, her energy is just tremendous.
She's from the island of Kohama in
Okinawa. In the last 300 years, this is
the longest lived of um humanity that's
documented. Dr. Yunqing Yun Lee and
Chinese always put their last name
first. So, Ching Yun Lee died at 256
years of age. He's born in 1677, died
May 6,
1933. And he lives in a place that is
rich with rare earths in laboratory
animals. Rare earths double the lifespan
of laboratory animals compared to the
control group. Okay, we use them in
electronics. We know they're very
valuable for electronics, but also
they're required. Ubium, utrium,
neodymium, proadmium, europium, and
samarium. And of course, they're all in
the 90 essential nutrients and all 60
essential minerals. We need water for
life. We need oxygen for life. And you
need the 90 essential nutrients for
life. Your DNA, RNA, your genes, your
telomeirs, little end caps on your
chromosomes will fail without these
nutrients. You have to have them every
second, every minute, every hour, every
day, every week of every month of every
year. Otherwise, you're going to have
problems. It's just that simple. You
cannot live without them. You need 60
minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 amino acids,
three fatty acids. You have to have
them. Your genes, your DNA, RNA, and
telmirs must have these things.
Otherwise, you have the greatest genes
in the world, but they're not going to
perform. This is when I first understood
epigenetics.
Epigenetics has replaced genetics when
it comes to the understanding of
disease, longevity. This was a study we
did at the St. Louis when I was doing
all those autopsies back in the 1960s.
and 70s and ended up in that book which
is in the Smithsonian Institute, the
disease of exotic animals. And Monsanto
gave the St. Louis Zoo, because we're in
the newspaper all the time because of
these studies going on, um gave the St.
Louis Zoo a a
timed hydro hydro um ponic unit. Had
these big racks with all these trays and
had seeds from barley grass and on a
timer it would water and fertilize us.
And we would be able to harvest this
like weekly. It's just wonderful for the
zoo animals eating dry food and hay all
the time, no green grass. It's really a
wonderful thing. And Perkins, who was
from the um St. Louis Zoo obviously and
the um the TV show, okay, Mutual Omaha's
Wild Kingdom, uh said, "Okay, Wallik,
find out of what real value is this
hydro. Is it just fun for these animals?
Are we just, you know, wasting our time
or is it useful for them?" And so I was
able to steal eggs from the same
motherfather common malard ducks, farm
ducks. I stole a 100 eggs over a period
of three months. Put them in the
refrigerator just like you put human
frozen embryos in the freezer. Just put
them in the refrigerator. When I had
100, I divided them into four groups of
25. The first group of 25, I just gave
lettuce seed for six weeks. The second
group of 25, I gave um nothing but the
hydroponically grown uh barley grass.
And you can see it's about 10 15% maybe
even 20% bigger than the ones that just
got the lettuce. The one in the middle
with the
um little little scale or the little
ruler on it received the R chimprina
laboratory duck pellets. See it's double
the size of the other two. But the one
that really got optimal amounts of every
nutrient it need to maximize it genetic
potential for size and strength and
everything it can do was what we call
the Huey group. It got both the pellets,
the alphalfpha pellets from R Simprina
and the barley grass. Look at the
difference. They're the same exact gene,
same mother father incubated at the same
time. And so there's no doubt that this
is an epigenetic story here. In that
study, the center for biology of natural
systems. We eliminated 900 different
diseases in animals which still plague
people because we realized there were
nutritional deficiency. We increase the
nutritional supplementation zoo animals
and eliminate all the diseases. And of
course, this is what saved the panda.
The pandas were down to just maybe a
dozen pandas left in zoos and they were
about ready to all die out. And then
suddenly we heard about lingling, right?
Suddenly we had all these other baby
pandas. What's happening? I finally got
to do an autopsy on one of them and it
was just starving to death because
they're feeding it nothing but bamboo.
And so I said, "Let's give them some dog
food." Oh, you can't. This is an exotic
animal. You can't give them dog food. So
we gave them dry dog food and now we
have more pandas. We know what to do
with they got to give them birth
control. Okay. We've tripled the
lifespan of animals with this
information. And basically um if you
look back 60 years ago, an old dog was
eight years old. 108 old dog is 25. That
same u time span, we humans have added
two or three months to our lifespan. We
didn't triple it like we did for animals
because we're using drugs and we use
nutrition for animals. We eliminate
every birth defect you can name and 10
times that many can't in animals by
supplementing preconception. And I urge
everybody, I urge everybody, when you're
getting a couple that's dating strong, a
couple that's getting engaged, or a
couple that's getting married, do not
give them a gift card. Do not give them
monogram towels. Do not give them a
linen set to start their household. Give
them the 90s essential nutrients, and
then you won't be a grandmother
babysitting a special needs child. How
did rich people get their minerals back
thousands of years ago? They'd give
grave robbers big bags of silver and
gold to get mummies and bring them
mummies. They grind up the mummies into
mummy dust and they would use mummy dust
as a condiment like salt and pepper on
their food. They're getting the minerals
from the mummy's bones and skin and
vitamins from their livers and so forth.
They did get some supplements that way
and they lived longer and healthier.
Now, obviously, uh people who were
slaves and and subsistance farmers and
and people who were just um carpenters
couldn't afford big bags of gold and
silver to get mummies. Where'd they get
their minerals? Well, Scientific
American did a wonderful story on why
people began to live longer, were
healthier, were smarter, did things,
invented language and so forth, invented
um writing, and they said it was all
because of cooking food. It all happened
when food began to be cooked. That's
exactly right. But it wasn't because of
the cooked food, but it began when food
was cooked, but not because of the
cooked food. Now, what was the universal
fuel 3, four, 5,000 years ago? Wood. No
matter where in the world they burned
fuel for heat, for cooking, for defense,
whatever it was, the fuel was always
wood. And what did they do with the wood
ashes every morning? They threw them in
the recycling bin to save the earth.
Where did the wood ashes go? It went
into the garden. Wood ashes aren't
ashes. 95% to 90% of the wood ashes are
really minerals that the tree sucked up
out of the ground. When you burnt the
wood, that powder that's left is
minerals. Sometimes it's a little gray
or black because there's some carbon
left over, but 95 to 98% of what we
would call wood ashes are really
minerals that the tree had sucked up out
of the ground. We threw it in the garden
and everybody knew it increased the
fertility. You had better yield and your
gardens did better when you put wood
ashes in there. But what they didn't
know and yet today they don't know and
I'm depending on all of you to share
this information. What they did know and
they don't know today is those plants
sucked up those minerals. When you ate
the pumpkins and the squash and the
ochre and the tomatoes and the bell
peppers and you ate the potatoes and the
onions and the peas and beans and
lentils and and corn that were grown
there, they sucked up all those minerals
and that's how you got your minerals.
You didn't know you were getting your
nutritional minerals that way, but you
did. This remained the same for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years until 3:00 in the afternoon,
Monday, September 4th, 1882. At 3:00 in
the afternoon, Monday, September 4th,
1882, on Pearl Street in New York City
and the bluff overlooking the
construction of the Brooklyn Bridge. It
all ended in a single heartbeat. We know
this because the story was in every
newspaper in the world. This fell here,
Thomas Edison, pulled the switch on the
first commercial electric generating
plant. Within 10 years, every
industrialized nation, including United
States, every town in every city in
every industrialized nation converted
from wood as a universal fuel to
electricity. Here comes the ultimate
question. How many wood ashes are left
over in your home every morning when you
use electricity to fuel your home? Zero.
Zero. Now, nobody knew what was
happening. They still don't. And again,
the most fertile and the most valuable
farmland in the world thousands of years
ago and yet today are flood planes
because every spring it would flood. And
as the water would recede, it would
leave silt and mud behind, minerals, if
you will, from mountains hundreds or
maybe thousands of miles upstream. And
people like this, of course, they'd plow
this in and renew the mineral content of
the soil. Because when you have minerals
in the food, it's because the plants are
pulling minerals out of the soil. They
don't know it. They don't need it. They
only need three, but they'll take up
anything that's soluble in the soil.
People liked it. Guess what? Today we
have 900,000 dams for hydroelectric
power. 900,000 dams for hydroelectric
power. And of course, there was an
unintended consequence, flood control.
Now, people thought that was good at
first. They didn't realize that we
destroyed the earth with flood control
because there's no renewal of the
minerals in the soil, the farmlands or
the plains or where it was flooding, the
valleys, and we've shut off the food
supply to ourel. We've shut off our
minerals for ourel as you'll see in a
moment. We have exact numbers by the US
Department of Agriculture. So things are
happening. It's all negative because
we've damned up the rivers. We cut off
the food supply to our farms. We've cut
off the food supply to the ocean. It's
over 100 feet deep of minerals that have
piled up since they built the Hoover
Dam. Nutritional minerals do not occur
in a uniform blank around the crust of
the earth. Nutritional minerals occur in
veins like chocolate and chocolate ice
cream.
Some places have little, some places
have none. Some places have three
minerals. Some places have 15, some
places have 25, some places have 40. But
you can see from this picture, which is
a satellite picture from a 100 miles up
that um the different colors and the
swirls and whirls represent different
minerals and different combinations of
minerals. So in the animal industry, so
every dairy cow is eating hay or beans,
soybeans grown in this area.
we would put a supplement of vitamins
and minerals in their alphalfpha pellets
maybe grown there are their soybeans
grown there. So put the vitamins,
minerals in their food. So we're
leveling the playing field. So every
dairy cow, no matter what part of that
picture she got her food from, she's
going to give us a maximum meal, say a
gallon and a half of milk instead of 10%
of the cows giving a pint and 20% giving
a quart instead of all 100% giving a
gallon and a half. It's predictable.
It's also very nutritial because a lot
of these minerals appear in the milk if
they're there. If they're not there,
obviously the cow can't make them. Now,
this is what makes longevity unique.
This is a compost pile. This compost
pile goes back into prehistoric days.
It's made out of 100% green leafy
plants. We know this because of the
chloroplast, the little chlor um
chlorophyll structures inside of plants,
green leafy things. And uh they contain
78 minerals, all 60 essential minerals
in optimal mountains. These people are
standing on a road that's 3,000 foot
elevation above sea level. That white
cap on this deposit is 15 to 25 foot
thick. And it represents a cap of marine
limestone. So obviously it was under the
sea for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years to make this
limestone. And um there's a 100 cubic
miles of this stuff here in this
deposit. 100 cubic miles. We know this
from drillings and soundings because oh
gosh 50 75 years ago people are looking
for oil. They're looking for coal. Uh
they're looking for natural gas in these
places and they said what is this stuff?
This isn't what we're looking for and
they just deserted
it. Of course this is something that is
incorporated into our 90 essential
nutrients getting the 60 essential
minerals from this deposit. We knew in
1936 our soil was depleted in minerals.
This is US Senate document 264 and it
was a two-year hearings done by the US
Senate to determine why our soils were
dead. Why did we have the dust bowl? Why
did uh we have the great depression.
They blamed it on depletion of minerals
in the soil in 1936. But nobody proposed
the reason why our soil was depleted. If
you ask even yet today environmentalist
professors of agriculture at big
agricultural universities, you ask them
why is our soil so depleted of minerals.
always say because of poor farming
farming practices, because of poor
farming practices. That's not true.
Nothing has changed as far as farming
practices. We plow, we plant, we
harvest. We plow, we plant, we harvest.
And so what is it? Well, no more wood
ashes in the gardens. No more silt from
floods. And we've cut off the food
supply to our land. Cut off the food
supply to our oceans. That's why we're
in trouble. This is one that really
disturbs me. Our baby food, according to
the Food Chemistry Journal, which comes
out every month. I read it faithfully
every month. And this one came out April
16th, 2012. They looked at the top eight
baby formulas from the standpoint of
pollution and from nutritional value.
They said these baby formulas we're
talking talking about infamile, similac,
gerbers, ones you're very familiar with,
very well respected. These baby foods
contain less than 20% of the required
nutrients needed for proper development
of our babies. We're talking about 20%
of the minerals and vitamins our babies
need is all you're going to get in
giving them these baby food. If you
don't supplement, you're going to wind
up burying them like Joe Biden buried
his son Bo. Steve Jobs mother buried him
and I wad his mother buried him. Okay?
You're going to wind up burying your
children if you don't supplement them
because it's not in the food anymore.
Even from the very beginning, okay,
these baby formulas, you must
supplement. We do it in animals. We got
great results. We have to do it in
people. We're going to have to do this.
The government has failed us. And guess
what? The medical system has failed us
terribly and somebody needs to go to
jail. This is a 100red-year study from
1914 to
2014. And of course, they referred back
to US Senate document 264 published in
1936. Our farm cells are depleted of
vital minerals and as a result, our
foods are literally starved of
nutrition. Medicine cannot um compensate
for this deficiency. US Senate document
1936. And the minerals in our soil over
the past hundred years 1914 to 2014 have
been depleted by 85%. You can see the
chart and the graph on the right you can
see the the
extreme dip in the mineral values of our
soil. Okay. Then in the bottom line
again this comes from last year 2014
USDA the United States Department of
Agriculture reports that 95% of all
Americans are minally deficient. What
more do you need? What more do you need
to understand that you must supplement?
No matter how well you eat, you're a
billionaire, it doesn't matter. You're
an athlete, it doesn't matter. If you're
a farmer, it doesn't matter. If you
don't supplement, you're in trouble.
Worse yet, if you don't supplement and
supplement your children, your children
are in trouble. Remember, the experts
are saying that our children, our
children will be the first generation
Americans that do not live as long as
their parents. To me, that's very, very
scary. But we have the power. We have
the knowledge to fix this. But we're
going to have to be very proactive here
because the government's not going to do
And guess what? The doctors aren't going
to do it. I want you to look at these
maps in the United States again. But I
want you to look at the demographics
here. Look at the worst of the worst.
And here the dark blue.
Okay, this is disability rates. Look at
the dark blue ones, which is the worst
of the worst.
31% the dark blue states of disability.
Look at this one. And this one, you look
at this one. This is the heart age
compared to the actual chronological
age. The ones in the dark burgundy are
the worst of the worst. Same
demographic. Look at this one. Heart
disease. Same demographic. Southeastern
states, the old Confederate states, the
states in the Great Lakes area, and west
of the Mississippi River, the Indian
reservations in the uh Northwest and the
Southwest. Okay. And now we're going to
look at
cancer. Same thing. Old Confederate
States, the states around the Great
Lakes and the Northwest and the
Southwest where the Indian reservations
are. Eastern seabboard, worst of the
worst life expectancy, as you'd expect
with all these terrible diseases being
the worst in those places. Same
demographics. The blue areas, this is by
county, actually live 25 years longer
than the ones in the orange and the
yellow and the red, both in the old
Confederate States, the Great Lakes
areas out west, Northwest, and the
Indian reservations in the Southwest. is
both for males and females. The way
we've been doing this for 38 years and
we've been doing this commercially for
38 years is to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients. And of course we
have a thousand products and it's very
difficult for a stranger to come along
and look at all say oh my gosh they
throw their hands up. What do I do? Is
there a key to this? And of course the
FDA won't let us say for this disease
use this product. They don't like that.
So we had to come at this a different
way. What we had to do was come up with
systems
where one program dealt with many many
diseases. Okay? And you can't use the
cure word. So we had to do it in a
different way. So let's look at what we
call the basic healthy start pack.
There's three products in there. Has 245
nutrients. Many will be in the near
future declared essential. So we're
already putting them in there. But it
also has the 90 essential nutrients, 16
minerals, 16 vitamins, 12 amino acids,
three fatty acids in optimal amounts for
perfect biochemical nutrition for a 100
pounds of human flesh for a month. You
give it to a 50 pound kid, it's a
two-mon supply. Give it to a 30 pound
kid, it's a three-month supply. Give it
a 200lb person, you need two of these
per month. A 300lb person, you need
three per month, and so on. And this is
the basic stuff. Now, I've essentially
been doing it, not this farm, but I've
been doing it personally for 68 years.
I haven't been sick in 68 years. Never
even had a cold. I've never had any
surgery. I've never been on a
prescription medication. My resting
pulse without prescription, without a
drug, without any medication is 90 over
60. My resting pulse without any
medication is 36. Now, it does spike
when I get angry or upset. It'll spike
to 39, but it's been that way since I
was 18 years old when I was wrestling
for the University of Missouri and
playing football in high school for four
years in lettering in football and
wrestling. So, this is our basic
program. If um you don't have a lot of
money, this will cost you about $3 a day
for the average person per 100 pounds of
body weight. And this is what I've been
doing. The healthy essentially the
healthy start pack. But let's say you
have something like um you're overweight
by 50, 75, 100 pounds or more, 200 lb,
300 lb. You want the healthy weight loss
pack. We have everything in there you
need to give your body what it needs so
your cravings go away, so your munchies
go away. And we give your body what it
likes so that it will give you
everything it needs. It'll make what it
can to keep you in the healthy weight
range. And you'll lose anywhere from a
half a pound to two pounds a day. And
you'll never gain the weight back as
long as you stay on this program. And
then of course, if you have diabetes,
type two, type one, if you have anxiety
attacks, panic attacks, narcolepsy,
anything that has to do with blood sugar
problems, um hypoglycemia, or active
hypoglycemia, you want the healthy blood
sugar pack. One of those per 100 pounds
of body weight. When you have diabetes,
you just take your fasting blood sugar
uh before you medicate yourself. And as
your blood sugar drops, you just do what
your doctor says. Reduce your
medication. If your blood sugar goes up,
you do what your doctor says. Take more
medication and you'll know when it's
time to get off your medication. Uh
anti-aging, healthy body pack. People
who have wrinkles and age spots and just
are tired all the time because they're
in their 70s and 80s. you give them the
healthy anti-hygene pack and the the
body's defenses can get rid of the age
spots when you give it the raw materials
to do that. Then of course we have the
healthy brain and heart pack. The
healthy brain and heart pack actually
gives you everything you need to deal
with over I don't know about 147
different diseases and we're talking
about Parkinson's disease, Lucaric's
disease which is ALS also MS, multiple
scerosis, Huntington's disease,
Alzheimer's disease and all the other
dementias also congestive heart failure,
cardiammyopathy heart disease, coronary
artery disease and a history of
thrombotic stroke. The healthy brain and
heart pack one per 100 pounds of body
weight. Okay. And then you have the
healthy body digestive pack. you have
reflux, belching, burping, bloating,
gas, these sorts of things. You want the
um healthy digestive pack. And there is
no such thing as acid reflux. It really
should be renamed lack of acid reflux,
okay? Because you really don't have
enough stomach acid. So yeast will grow
in there, bacteria will grow in there,
and they ferment carbohydrates and sugar
making gas and causing all these
problems. So uh my suggestion is if you
have reflux don't take any of these PPIs
the proton pump inhibitors so that you
are going to make less stomach acid
because in two three four five years
time you're going to have 15 disease you
didn't have before they all be
nutritional deficient diseases. So you
want the healthy digestive pack one per
100 pounds of body weight. Healthy body
athletic pack. If you're working hard in
your trade and you're sweating you want
this one. If you're playing sports on
the weekend or you're just kind of two
three nights a week you're going to the
gym and running on the treadmill and
working on the machines. you want to use
a healthy body athletic pack. And also,
if you have people in your family who
are in school and they're playing
sports, uh whether it's um in in grade
school, junior high, high school, or
university, or if they're trying out for
the Olympic team, or you know,
professional football players, or even
if you have somebody in the military,
because the government does not give our
military vitamins, minerals. They give
them dry food. They give them canned
food, but they do not get any vitamins,
minerals. I have surveyed thousands of
military personnel, many of whom have
PTSD. They do not get any vitamins,
minerals from the government. So if you
have somebody you love who's in the
military, I'd urge you to give them the
healthy body athletic pack. It has all
the minerals that are missing that
result in the diseases that are
diagnosed as PTSD, depression, bank
depression, bipolar disease, and so on.
And then healthy body bone and joint
pack. If you have arthritis,
osteoporosis, bone to bone arthritis,
osteopenia, osteoporosis, periodonal
disease, which is osteoporosis of the
face, you take the healthy bone and
joint pack and guess what happens? Your
body has the ability to rebuild itself.
Your body wants to heal itself, but you
have to give it raw materials for that
to happen. You cannot build a house
without brick and mortar. You cannot
build a house without roofing shingles.
You cannot build a house without wood
for framing and infrastructure. You need
nails and screws and bolts and nuts.
Okay? Same way with their body. You may
have the best genes in the world, but
without the 90 essential nutrients, as
they say in France, there ain't nothing
going to happen. Okay? And so I I just
hope you remember the fact that we have
less than 20% of the nutrients necessary
in our baby
foods. Our kids generation will be the
first generation in America that do not
live as long as their parents. It's not
a genetic thing. It's not destined. But
if you don't supplement them, that that
prediction will come true. So, I urge
you to give everybody you know for
birthdays, holidays, anytime a presents
due, for um graduations and schools and
so forth, getting married, getting
engaged, going out together on a regular
basis. Give them the 90 essential
nutrients. Our babies will be born
normal. People will live a long time.
Your kids will outlive you, which is the
way it's supposed to be. And I want to
thank you for being such a great
audience. Contact your Young Associate
and find out how you get involved.
become part of the Youngeivity Nation
and we're going to save America. Even
more important than that, with this
information, we can save the world. And
God bless you.